10 Things I wish I knew when starting a
YouTube channel and so grab your
notebook something to take notes with
you want to capture all 10 we actually
have two bonus tips our special guests
today um shared some of their wisdom
ahead so we've organized this session so
you can capture actually all 12 tips
that are really going to help you
shorten your learning curve get results
faster and plus you're going to love
hearing some insights from their two
stories let me first introduce you to Dr
Andrew furland uh Dr Andrea welcome to
the challenge oh thank you so much sh
for inviting me um can you tell us a
little bit about when you started your
YouTube channel and what it is you do on
YouTube yeah I am a physician in Canada
I am in Toronto and I treat people with
chronic pain and um in 2019 I started
this channel to educate my own patients
because I I needed a little bit more
information to pass to them I don't have
time time in my clinic so I started this
and um now I'm posting one video a week
I started with only one month once every
month and my channel is growing I I'm
almost at 600,000 subscribers and 53
million views in
total your story is so inspiring and I
can't wait to get into the tips and
lessons you've learned along the way but
I also now want to welcome Tim from
Adventure Tim Tim tell us about your
YouTube Journey when did you and what is
it you do on YouTube yeah thanks Sean U
real honored to be here by the way um I
started my journey about 2013 um when I
posted a video to promote a uh a charity
event I had a um a family member who
passed away uh from cancer and I wanted
to promote that event originally on
YouTube that's how I kind of started um
but over the course of the journey uh my
my uh my my vision and my Niche has
changed from things like travel videos
oh my God you found that one that's I
found
it um from like travel videos through to
like Adventure um challenge kind of
videos to my latest Niche or one that's
worked for me which is mainly like GoPro
videos and still some travel videos as
well so by being able to uh find my
Niche and it took a while on my journey
is actually really really helped me
build up a great community of um of
followers and supporters from all over
the world and uh I'm just uh so thankful
for what I've learned from V over the
last couple of years it's made a really
big difference and uh yeah um my Channel
at the moment is over 880,000
subscribers and at the start of this
year I only got Monet monetized uh in
January so to go from 1,000 to 880,000
I've been very blessed I've had a couple
of uh videos that have gone wild for me
and um yeah so here I am talking to you
this is a bit of a dream come true man
so thank you very much well so grateful
you're here and this is a challenge this
is a price privilege because you get to
learn from people with 83,000 600,000
subscribers plus we're going to look
into that insight you're you're not
joking about having some parabolic
videos 24 million views in the last 28
days and 68,000 new subscribers is this
a glitch I could see this being a glitch
is that really what just happened in the
last month yeah it's kind of funny
because back in May I filmed a busker or
a street performer uh in the main street
of my city and um it took me this this
video here took me about five minutes to
film uh
probably about 10 minutes to kind of
mess around with it and I uploaded it
and um I put it to a whole different
from bunch of sites stuff that I kind of
learned through V places to put it to
and it kind of started off slowly and
then all of a sudden it just kind of
grew and it grew and I would be um I I I
I work away from home sometimes and i'
be getting all these messages coming
through for this one short and I
couldn't believe it it just kind of took
off and I remember once you actually
said how um a rising tide lifts All
Ships and what this one short did was it
it brought so many more people to my
channel who maybe would never have sort
of um uh seen it in the first place and
so all of a sudden I've had crazy
viewership from all over the world this
this short in particular has blown up
really big in places like um India and
Pakistan and Bangladesh and those people
have kind of remixed it and they've
actually used the music from this basker
and in their own kind of videos and
their own shorts I've actually even
reached out to the bus Grom self and I
kind of told him about this video his
name is can Master Smash and he's an
incredible uh like street musician he
performs around the world sometimes and
uh even he's kind of Blown Away by the
success from this little kind of short
video um uh it's it's quite
extraordinary yeah I mean 32 million
views 1.3 million likes and we do say in
V you're one video away from changing
your life changing your business a
rising tide lifts All Ships so that can
become an entry point to people
discovering that you and so I'm exced
decided to unpack that well let's kick
it off um actually with you Tim and
we're going to go through these tips and
then I'll bring Dr Andre on tip number
one we're going through 12 tips that we
wish we knew when we were starting tip
number one is set realistic expectations
one of the things you said as we were
doing our pre uh conversation was how
much time it takes to create videos and
how much goes into the process break
down your process and how you've kind of
learned to have like the right mentality
when it comes to creating
content yeah uh I really kind of think
you take every opportunity to kind of um
you know film and film things and
embrace things I can't carry my camera
everywhere uh because you let never
quite know what's going to happen like
you never know what sort of circumstance
you're going to come across and you just
never know when you're going to find
those sort of golden moments or those
things that are kind of going to blow up
for you like with this video here it
took me almost no time to film and then
um upload and I've had other videos I
worked on for months and I've spent
weeks tweaking and filming and working
on voiceovers and stuff and they haven't
done anything they've got like you know
if I'm lucky 100 views it's really kind
of frustrating but then you have
something like this which kind of comes
along or some from my other shorts which
come along as well and they sort of I
don't know they just kind of surprise
you so you've got to always kind of um
just kind of have some goals and it's
really important to have some goals but
kind of like be prepared to kind of like
go beyond that too you never know what's
going to happen right you never know
where it's going to come from but if you
just keep working and keep grinding man
like you know good things will come your
way
yeah I love that and Dr Andrea I'm
curious on point number one setting
realistic
expectations I mean we're g to talk
about this later you got a book deal
you're winning Awards you're getting
invited to you know all throughout
Canada all of these things but how how
was the process when you first started
creating videos and tell us chronic pain
tell us the pain I mean learning video
uploading like you know learning all
this stuff break that down yeah so in
I'm I'm a doctor so I have a busy
practice I teach students I'm a
professor of medicine at University of
Toronto and I still have I find time to
write those videos and to write the
scripts to do the research to film I
have now my son who edits my videos for
me but I do the post marketing of the
videos and in the beginning I could do
only one a month and that's how I
learned that was my capacity so don't
try to overdo because then you will not
have good quality for each video I I'm
very conscious about the quality of each
video I don't let I don't publish
anything that is lower the standards of
what I think is high quality but that
takes time and now I learned about um
how to do things in like batch recording
I book one uh Saturday every five six
weeks I go to the hairdresser she colors
my roots because I'm getting old I put
makeup up get my outfits and I record
six seven eight nine videos long videos
in one day here is my studio this is
where I record and then I record a lot
of shorts uh about each video so at the
end of the day I have 50 something
things on my camera and my iPhone um so
you need to do what is what works for
you don't don't try to overdo and burn
out
quickly man that's so great and just to
highlight a few points you're using your
phone to film yes no no now I got a can
I I got a camera for just because it was
hard to get the videos out of my iPhone
but uh I I reached 100,000 subscribers
with just my iPhone that's a quote I
reached 100,000 subscribers with just my
phone do you know what Canon camera you
just got I'm sure people are curious M50
nice and so it is nice one of the
advantages of having a separate camera
is exactly right moving the files off of
a smartphone can be can take a while
versus like pop the SD card out put put
it in the computer so um that is really
inspiring so number one is set really
realistic expectations number two is
YouTube has an advantage over other
platforms and staying with you Dr Andrea
you talked about how some of the
observations you noticed about YouTube
content versus other social media break
those down yeah no oh YouTube is by far
the best at least for my purposes which
is educating the public people who have
uh pain chronic pain this is lowback
pain fibromyalgia arthritis headaches
because it offers them my my my audience
is older people they have more chronic
pain but I also have a lot of children
teenagers and adults um but they they
chronic pain affects how you concentrate
and how you memorize things so having
the ability to show to talk to them with
my own words so then if I speak a a
complicated medical term I can show the
words so they can read and I also
increase the accessibility because a lot
of people don't understand English and I
put close captions in 5506 languages all
my videos have closed captions in 56
language which is also my population I
didn't do this to reach the whole world
I did this because my patients who come
here in Toronto they um a lot of them
English is not the first language so it
helps them to understand what is their
disease that they have what I'm asking
them to
do man it's powerful and I'm curious
Adventure Tim um when you think about
YouTube I know you mentioned you're
posting it on all different platforms
shorts especially but what do you love
about YouTube in terms of your channel
and I'm also curious have you found in
terms of money coming in like this this
dash cam video has
118,000 uh views I wonder if any
affiliate marketing has worked for you
or anything else you've learned because
of YouTube
specifically yeah um affiliate marketing
hasn't really kind of uh worked in in my
favor I've got I'm an Amazon affiliate
um I've reached out for to a few
companies but nothing's kind of really
sort of happened in that space
unfortunately but what I love about
YouTube over other platforms is just how
you can have a video that's like two or
three years old and that can still
provide um benefits and be helpful to
people who who happen to find your
content I'm still getting comments about
that video which I did over two years
ago and other ones as well which you
know just kind of sound like you know
like a simple idea one was like hooking
up your connecting your GoPro to a TV
you know those sort of small videos and
you spoke yesterday about answering
specific questions those little things
can really kind of help and people find
your comment like for years and years to
come if you have good com comment
content and also even like some of my
old travel videos will sometimes get
people to kind of you know you know
watch when they go on holiday to a place
as well and you can't really get that
with other platforms like Instagram or
Tic Tac Tik Tok or Facebook things are
things arrive on on those platforms and
they're gone very quickly and then they
like they never come back again but with
YouTube being able to find content and
even old content which is like quite
often Evergreen content really works uh
is is where I find you like YouTube is
Just A Cut Above the Rest I love that
which brings us to tip number three
which is the creator economy is booming
and Dr Andrea you talked a little bit
about here's the quote the whole
industry is gravitating around YouTube
can you unpack that a little bit for us
yes I I I find that um YouTube opens the
door for so many business and so many
collaborations and so many Partnerships
I didn't do a lot of um um I don't do
sponsored videos but I am approach it
Shan every day I get two at least two or
three emails of people who want me to
collaborate with with me that they want
me to sell products on my videos talk
about the supplements talk about this
exercise uh equipment talk about this
I'm not doing that because I I am very
reluctant about what I promote I do talk
about some products but they are I only
have affiliate marketing with Amazon so
I put the links on Amazon and uh but
also open the doors for a lot of other
things like travel Awards and
conferences and podcasts and things that
I would never be able to reach just
because people see me on YouTube so my
reach has a professional educator a
professor uh is amazing because now I
can uh I've be invited to go to
conferences that I would never be able
to go if it was not for YouTube for
example yeah that's powerful and it kind
of actually ties into my fourth point
that I captured which is Success on
YouTube opens new doors of opportunity
and you were talking about that and I'm
curious Tim since starting your YouTube
channel um what have some of the life
experiences or opportunities that have
come your
way yeah I've been in touch a couple of
companies have been in touch with me
about um doing reviews of their products
uh which has been kind of great you know
and you get to sort of try uh to review
things or products that you would
wouldn't normally but like for me um you
know like I'm I'm just only my main
source of income is AdSense at the
moment uh but you know the plan is to
kind of like now I've got a decent
number of subscri of subscribers and a
community Through YouTube I can now
approach a lot of companies who like
early in my journey weren't interested I
remember like like GoPro I feature a lot
of GoPro products and I went to them
like once I hit a th subscribers and I
was so excited I was like here we go man
this is like totally what I want I'll be
able to you know get part of their
program but they were like oh yeah a
th000 isn't like enough you know come
back and see us later on and so like now
I'm approaching them again a second time
with more of a community behind me and
more of like um you know like an
influence so I can say Hey listen you
know like I've got this product I'm
promoting like a lot of your products
for free anyway because I want to help
other people get the most out of like
your product you know let's like kind of
work together let's come on board you
know so powerful and um going back to Dr
Andrea here number five is choose a
clear channel topic so Dr Andrea what
did you learn with this tip
yeah uh just for the previous topic what
the channel opened the door for me too
was to get my book published so the
publisher approached me when I I
approached the publisher and then uh
because I had 100,000 subscribers I was
able to close the deal with the
publisher but talking about yeah yes so
the the topic that you ask about the
Clear Channel topic uh that's so
important because I I think uh if you
don't have a clear topic for your
Channel people get confused so I only
talk about chronic pain and then people
ask me you know they write comments they
send me emails saying can you talk about
this topic in medicine and high blood
pressure and thyroid problems and other
things and I say no I only talk about
chronic pain and the Temptation is great
because I like to talk about um you know
many things on my channel but I do have
to focus because that's what my that's
what I learned with you that's what they
sign my audience signed up to hear me
talking about chronic pain so don't
confuse
them yeah that's a really powerful tip
and you know Zig Ziggler says our
ultimate goal is to be a meaningful
specific not a Wandering generality but
I definitely want to talk to Tim about
this as well because Tim has followed a
current trajectory that's similar to
mine meaning that um I it wasn't super
clear to me upfront I mean I think Dr
Andrea as a chronic pain specialist with
such specific expertise
and now on the other side of things
600,000 subscribers and there's no
question you're going to go to a million
um it was maybe yes VRA and our
messaging encourage you to Niche down
and it's so powerful you're staying
focused but Tim it sounds like earlier
you were talking about you've been on
this journey of Discovery so unpack for
us a little bit how now you really F you
eventually found niching down on GoPros
GoPros you love traveling so it kind of
tied into that but what has the journey
been like for you like trying to disc
ever for those that are especially
watching this that are like okay I
understand the power of that but I'm
multi-passionate and I kind of want to
just start by experimenting I'm not sure
if I want to commit to a clear topic yet
yeah I think that's a great question um
I think you have to kind of try and find
what your Vibe is and um try to find out
what sort of works for you and what
you're passionate about as well because
if you choose a topic which you're not
really passionate about you're not going
to stick along for the journey because
it is a marathon and it's not a Sprint
you know you don't get that success
straight away overnight so I kind of
dabbled in a few different areas um what
I found to is like uh like my my my
original kind of travel videos was I
worked overseas quite a bit so my plan
was that I could film stuff that I was
doing say in the Middle East and I could
send it home via YouTube to show my
family and friends what I was up what I
was up to and that kind of worked out
okay for them but it didn't kind of
always reach a broader audience and then
once I kind of like found your program
and kind of I was able to kind of get a
bit more Direction and what one thing I
really liked about your program too was
like when I first joined it back in 2021
because I remember I was going through a
real flat patch uh in my life I hated my
job um my wife was sick in a hospital
and I kind of joined the challenge like
just like this one here and I kind of
heard people like you and Heather and
Omar and Nolan all kind of speak um
about you know like what kind of about
your own Journeys as well and I at that
point I kind of felt like I didn't have
anything really much to offer rather
than just my occasional little videos
and I thought I'm not an expert in
anything and how can I answer specific
questions like I don't I'm not an expert
in say GoPros or travel or anything but
then I just kind of listen to you guys
and I got some tips and I got that
belief and that inspiration and from and
from things like that I was able to kind
of type into go into like YouTube you
know um how to GoPro something and then
come up with like how to use a GoPro as
a dash cam and I was able to kind of
follow down that pathway and that video
has actually you know the fact that it's
got over 100,000 views just really kind
of blows my mind that was the one that
really kind of started the ball really
rolling for me after having other random
views on like you know travel in
Indonesia or or Singapore or whatever
which kind of you know kind of started
going a little way you a little way
towards getting somewhere this having a
specific topic was able to kind of
really help me focus and then once I had
that one that sort of really worked I
was able to work out the next one and
you kind of you kind of all of a sudden
all the pieces all kind of start
together you kind of find the steps that
you need to follow to kind of get that
success and you have the audience that
comes to you and the greatest thing for
me is to be able to help someone else
you know like um for someone to kind of
like write to me like recently I had a
guy say hey man I was trying to find a
video about how to use um Time Warp on
the GoPro and I looked at a whole bunch
of videos but yours was the one yours
was the one that kind of helped me you
know and I just filmed that video in the
park it was a windy day like looking
back now it doesn't look so great that
was able to help somebody and that is
the biggest Buzz out of this whole out
of this whole scenario you know I kind
of found a niche that kind of worked for
me and I was able to help others you
know and that's and that's that's the
payback for me that's the ultimate
payback well Tim a couple things I want
to unpack number one I appreciate your
kind words and it's so cool to like have
this full circle moment from getting to
connect with you at a challenge just
like this in 2021 here we are now you're
on the V show now you're in a challenge
session um and so thank you so much for
sharing all that two you know one of the
Nuggets we were talking about in VIP
yesterday which there is still two more
VIP sessions if anybody's interested but
we were really going deep and people
were saying hey what's most important is
it tags is it description is it title is
it thumbnail and I was like well in
reverse order tags are kind of least
important but you should still use the
box if YouTube gives it to you you
should do the description right I think
next would be titled second place is
thumbnail but they're like what's what's
number one what's the number one most
important
thing and I was like was actually topic
like if you have the greatest thumbnail
and title but the topic isn't what
people care about and so it's so cool to
hear full circle you doing V and and
discovering topics that got 100,000
views how do you didn't think that how
to use a GoPro as a dash cam was going
to be that big of a video and one thing
I want to point out tactically for our
challenge Community here is because I
have I IQ installed I can see this
little overlay of a blue number that
just gives me data on other people's
videos it says seven vph vph stands for
views per hour the video is a year old
you said maybe two years old and if um
this video is still getting seven views
every hour like this hour during the
session seven people are going to watch
your video from a year plus ago and you
talked about how the time warp video
changed someone's life how to use time
war on your GoPro that got one point
that's getting 1.1 view view per hour
you might go like only one view we had a
year old video that's 24 views a day
every single day whether you upload a
new video or not this is why YouTube is
the greatest because you get views while
you snooze and so that just speaks to
the power of topic though the ability to
research find those topics that resonate
with people which leads us really to
number six and you had already really
touched on that was commit to continued
learning commit to continued learning
now Dr
Andrea you um mentioned this and you
talked about I learned a new science
YouTube bology or youology youology you
I've never heard anyone say that word
I'm gonna drop it in the chat but break
down the value that you have found with
all your YouTube success of why a
commitment to continued learning has
been important for you
YouTubey yeah because I'm a scientist so
I like I I think YouTube It's a science
it's not just an art is an arch too but
um you do need to work know how it works
I you know when I started I had no idea
so you need to learn how to read the
analytics you need to learn what other
people are doing you need to learn how
to do a good thumbnail you need to learn
so many things and you need to find a
school so a lot of people ask me nowan
they say where did you learn all of this
I and then I say I learn on YouTube
watching YouTube videos here and there
that's how I found think media and then
I tell them I went to a YouTube school
which is the V Academy um and then they
say but how do you find the schools
where do you go and um that's the long
the lifelong learning I also subscribe
to the YouTube creators Channel they
every week they post a lot of things
that what's happening on YouTube and uh
you have to keep learning because things
change so quickly and uh having a school
not only having the materials the binder
but also having the classroom I think
for me the most uh important thing was
who do I ask a question because this
feels so alone being a YouTube Creator
I'm here with my camera and I post these
things and then watch who do I ask a
question if I have um a problem and
having the Facebook group of the V
Academy is amazing having you know my
colleagues there my classmates who are
struggling with the same problem you
post you post a question there and then
immediately in a few hours there will be
a lot of comments trying to respond and
helping to answer that question I I
think um without this nobody can be
successful because there's no well
there's now your book The YouTube
Secrets I have the both versions but it
is different from having like a
professor a tutor a coach that can help
you with the questions that you're
having right now well I appreciate uh
your kind words and yeah we really
believe that Community is everything we
need each other we don't get anywhere
alone iron sharpens iron and uh and we
have found at think media we continue to
learn and we invest in ourselves um as a
team and um in all the different skill
sets for building a business online
marketing digital marketing social media
YouTube um but I'm excited for number
seven because it's tap into the power of
YouTube shorts now we really had a
preview on this one we'll start with Tim
and then Dr Andrea I am curious about
your workflow because you mentioned
you're shooting shorts on shoot days but
Tim do you have anything to add truly a
short Change of your life I mean 32
million views it's crazy to see a video
with 1.3 million likes like that's such
H it's a big uh reach so that has
already kind of proven YouTube shorts
I'm just curious though um how many
shorts are you posting how are you
producing them and why do you believe in
YouTube
shorts yeah I was a little bit light to
the guy when it come to YouTube shorts I
was always kind of like really pushing
every week to get that get that one
video out a week um which is what is
sometimes quite difficult to do and then
I was going away for a while um and I
was going to an area where I wasn't sure
I was going to have internet access so I
was like you know what I'm going to uh
make some shorts actually repurpose some
of my old like longer content and sort
of chop it up into shorts and then kind
of publish it on a regular basis while
um in like a remote location and then
what I kind of found was that some of
those little shorts were were actually
just blowing up so much bigger than the
original videos and um that I that I
could imagine like I I spent some time
in mour uh earlier on this year I made
this video of things to do on Melbourne
free things got a couple hundred views
wasn't sort of doing too much and then I
chopped it all up into little shorts and
those little shorts were are now getting
thousands of views and they're kind of
bringing people to my channel who would
never come there before and so you can
just kind of go out and film um your own
shter shorts or you can kind of create
it from your own content and um Nolan
made a makes has made a brilliant video
about how to repurpose your content to
make it into shorts and that really kind
of turbocharged things for me so all of
a sudden I'm in a remote location and my
shorts were coming out two or three
times a week some of them and that kind
of had put the presence of my channel
out there like like not just once a week
with that one long form video that
people may not have had time to watch
the whole thing but with a 30 second
short that might give it a shot or it
appears in like like YouTube shorts feed
and then all of a sudden more and more
people are coming to your channel and I
I really hit I really hit the gold mine
when I when I hit that when I had that
one video of that Busker which just kind
of went just crazy town for me right but
also those other little ones too have
kind of have helped as well so I kind of
look at it this way although this one
video has done amazing things I wouldn't
have got that success with that one
video without having all those other 250
270 videos along the way in that
learning process and um yeah shorts has
just really turbocharged my channel and
I really highly encourage everyone to to
have a crack at shorts you know it can
just put your name out there on a more
consistent basis and you know it's it's
really been a godsend for my Channel I
want to highlight something you said you
obviously had the breakout video 32
million views but you wouldn't have
gotten there if it wasn't for the
hundreds of other videos that got you
there and we are so big in in our VRA
Community about consistency about the
power of repetition about the power of
following a system and that as you work
the system the results follow there's a
good book called good to great and talks
about the flywheel effect it's kind of
like getting momentum but it also is the
fact that you're practicing learning
skills making mistakes and so even
though there's maybe it's kind of like
the phrase there's uh they're like oh
you're just an overnight success and
you're like yeah I mean I guess but but
overnight just took 300 uploads you know
in your like you know for like oh you're
just overnight success well yeah I mean
it only took five years but I suppose I
mean like there was the night that all
of a sudden the video went big and
that's when you put was on radar but
people don't see the perseverance and
the learning and the practice behind the
scenes so I want to encourage our
challenge community and the power of
perseverance and the power of starting
messy and the power of getting started
continuing to level up continuous
learning continuing to practice and then
all of a sudden when you're a smashing
success people will be like well you
came out of nowhere and you're like yeah
besides pain hardship challenges and I
suppose I mean you're just seeing so uh
so powerful and I do want to hear Dr
Andrea's experience with shorts you're
actually well what you mentioned was
that you're crafting them so do you
actually shoot two different forms of
content after you've done a long form
video are you putting out a short form
video what's your
workflow yeah so I tried to post one
shorts a day I did not have that
breakthrough that team had yet but I'm
persistent and I'm playing around with
different meth with music without music
with letters with no text different
things but what I do is I shoot my video
on my can my long video and then I have
my iPhone on a pedestal like this and
immediately with the same outfit I just
shoot you know maybe three four shorts
about that video that I just recorded
and then I release them over you know
the next weeks and I'm I'm playing
around like doing what Ting did do
something out of the
that an idea that I have and um I didn't
have the Breakthrough yet but I know I
will have it one day I will have my big
video my shorts that will blow out I
love that which brings us to number
eight which is adding value leads to
views and I want to start with Tim here
Tim you shared it's important to think
of the viewer and the value that you're
giving them I'm curious if that was like
a light bulb moment where maybe early on
you weren't thinking about the viewer as
much not that
it wasn't you didn't care about them but
just when did this become clear for
you yeah I kind of think that when you
kind of um when you kind of change your
direction and you start not just making
content for yourself you make it like
with the with the the thought of helping
other people you know I remember uh I
think you did an interview with Gary ve
once and he kind he kind of said
something how most people are making
selfish content they're making content
for themselves or like their trip to
Hawaii or I don't know in Australia or
whatever but once you kind of turn that
around and you start thinking how can I
help out the person who's taken the time
to click on my video to watch my video
that's when you start to get those wins
and you get those people communicating
with you and then you think okay I can
really make an impact here I can help
maybe change or better someone's life
and once you start doing that it's just
it's just such a buzz then you kind of
go on a different kind of path you know
like like you can still make your
content with your travel videos but as
long as you kind of give something to
the viewer or else they're not going to
stick around you know and people and
people care that you write back to them
as well and they they care that you put
the time in to kind of help them out um
that's always been like one of the
things I've really tried to do like my
whole journey is if someone has taken
the time to write a couple of lines
about video or short to respond to them
um with this viral video I was trying to
do that every day I'd have like days off
on my work commitments and I'd sit down
and say okay I want to reply to these
people but then hundreds and hundreds of
comments will kind of come through and
trying to respond to all them is quite
difficult but it's just really really
important to try to do the best you can
to try to give that value to make that
connection to show that someone who has
taken the time to look at your stuff
show that you care you really appreciate
what they've done you know because they
could have looked at someone else's
video they could have you know just
skipped your your content you know so
it's really really important to add as
much value as you can you know and
really not expect anything in return but
when they write some comment like you
know hey this has really kind of helped
me with my my GoPro videos or I've got
another smaller second Channel about
softball because I love playing softball
and I've been a softball coach and some
lady wrote to me the other day and said
hey man thank you so much for your
channel I've actually and your video
I've actually sent it to the girls on my
team to kind of help them learn how to
catch a softball right and so this is
just such an amazing feeling you know
I've added value by just creating a
video in the park and someone has found
that and it's kind of helped improve
their situation or or this softball team
and that's um that's that's such a win
you know for everybody you
know so powerful and I know Dr Andrea
has some very powerful things to share
around adding value as well I mean that
is the core of her Channel but we do I
think media talk about selfish content
versus service content and when we get
obsessed with yes our channel is built
around our own passion but when we think
about putting the viewer first I mean
it's it's almost biblical it's like when
you put other first love others as you
love yourself like think about value
like your income is directly correlated
to the amount of value you add to the
marketplace the algorithm rewards value
because that's what actually serves and
helps people and Dr Andrea I'm cuur
about curious about this because you
know I know that you're super humble and
uh like that talking about your success
like I really want you to kind of open
it up like the messages you get the the
difference like the awards it's like
this feedback loop of you publish in all
this content with helping people with
chronic pain the level of value it's out
of the world is insane break down your
thoughts on how adding value leads to
views yeah first of all when I do think
about each video I do a lot of research
I write the script I want to have the
best the upto-date information in that
video that's adding value do a good
research on your topic and then when I'm
recording I'm always looking at the
camera and I'm imagining one of my
patients sitting across the table and
I'm talking to that patient and it's
very personal you know I'm trying to
make that connection I'm talking to you
right now who is having pain and a
person who is having pain they're
suffering they're depressed they're
anxious it's hard for them to pay
attention and then I'm trying to connect
with them at this level and when they
write comments I Tred the best to
respond but there are so many comments I
can't anymore but I remember can I tell
a story about a a a person that wrote me
on Facebook uh saying that he he's in
Africa and he was telling me that his
wife had a stroke and I had a video very
successful video on my Channel that I
show exercise for shoulder pain but his
wife had a stroke and she was having
shoulder pain and he told me she was
trying to do the exercises to get better
and I knew that was the wrong kind of
exercise because if you have a stroke
you have to do different kinds of
exercise compared if it's just a
tendonitis of your shoulder so I had to
respond to him say I'm sorry I can't
give advice to your wife because I don't
give medical advice via YouTube or
social media but then I I I closed that
comment and I was crying and I said oh I
know how what kind of exercises she
should be doing how can I help her I had
an idea so I mailed I I messaged him
back and I said I'm going to do a video
speciic specifically for your wife so
then I had to do research again because
the exercise are different and I
recorded a video which is shoulder
exercise for shoulder pain after a
stroke and then he took a little short
video of her doing this exercise show to
me and I was so happy because she was
now doing the right exercises so that's
the kind of thing that brings me
satisfaction when I can help one person
in the middle of Africa who doesn't have
access to exercise or a physician like
me I mean it it literally is so
inspiring to imagine the fact that we
can create content that could help
people around the world you're doing it
in such a profound way and to help
people that don't have access to what we
maybe take for
granted um you've already touched on
number nine about caring and making
genuine connections clearly you're doing
that you're making specific videos for
somebody with a specific situation and
there are so many powerful things that
are shining through with car and making
genuine connections with others but Tim
you submitted something specific that
really resonated with me it said the
importance of treating your subscribers
like real people and not just a number
so what does that mean to you how do you
take action on number
nine yeah um I think it's really
important I think the way how the world
is today you are just a number in so
many different situations like whether
it's like on your your Medicare card or
your social security card or in
depending on what job you do so actually
see that person as a real person who's
got like real concerns and they got
their own kind of life and their own
issues kind of going with and if you
look at it as a person like you're
trying to help a friend or maybe you're
helping a stranger in some ways but you
you want to kind of like you know make
that connection and kind of say okay I
can see you need some help I've got a
little bit of knowledge here maybe I can
help you on your journey you know and
I've kind of found in the past I've had
people write me questions or write me
comments ments and I'll spend like a lot
of time trying to find the answers and
I'll write back and often people will be
like so grateful that be like hey man I
don't believe I can't believe you spent
that much time helping me out you've got
a subscriber like for life now because
you've actually gone that extra step
you've actually gone beyond what they
expected from some guy in front of a
camera half a world away you know to
kind of help them out and I think that's
really really key and by showing that
you care and showing that you want to
help people that's just going to keep on
compounding when it comes to your
subscribers and your use and you know it
kind of gives you that that good feeling
as well you know it's like okay I spent
an hour on my Friday afternoon kind of
helping this guy with a GoPro question
but now he can do what he needed to do
or he's he can film that event that
maybe before he couldn't or got the
right white balance settings you know or
the Right iso now and so I really kind
of think it's it's super important and
in this crazy world like I said that
that we don't forget the human you know
um on the other side of the keyboard
who's written those comments you know
Tim this whole thing in Dr Andrea
there's people that you're bringing to
tears too with just your service and how
you guys like that the place that you're
coming from the place of love the place
of care and you know what I think about
is this isn't a tactic although it is
tactical meaning we we have think media
talk about this internally with our team
all the time about how like one of our
core values is love above all and how
you know there's like it's kind of based
off Corinthians where it's like man if
I'm super talented if I had like
miraculous gifts if I was the best at
YouTube and all this other stuff but I
didn't have love I'd just be a
resounding gong I'd just be a clanging
symbol a lot of people have heard that
Corinthians verse at weddings and stuff
and that's our thing too is like if
we're good at YouTube we're good at
tactics we're good at all this stuff but
if we don't if we forget about people
and we forget about love and actually
caring about the end user then like
we've lost then ultimately we might as
well shut down but what's also
interesting is the world is craving that
genuine care the world is craving they
can feel it when you put the work work
into the research when you put quality
into a video and you respond to comments
and it also is probably the best
tactical strategy for a sustainable
career on YouTube because what a better
Foundation to build on than that
Foundation of love and so uh we are
going to get through our final three
tips because we're taking it all to 12
but I think one or two people might want
a recap of all the points we are going
through the things we wish we knew when
we were starting YouTube to super
successful creators um we have Dr Andrea
furland helping people with chronic pain
and we have Adventure Tim media helping
people with GoPros and creating travel
videos and um here's what we've learned
so far and then we're going to get into
the final tips get ready to fill in the
blanks of any notes that you miss number
one is set realistic expectations number
two YouTube has an advantage of all
other platforms number three the Creator
economy is booming number four success
on YouTube opens new doors of
opportunity number five choose a clear
channel topic number six commit to
continued learning number seven tap into
the power of YouTube shorts number eight
adding value leads to views and number
nine care and make genuine connections
which brings us to number 10 which is
not a lot it's something that not a lot
of people talk about and so as I was
reading the notes Dr Andre wrote this
and it really hit me you actually hit
the Spider-Man quote which is one of my
favorite quotes um with great influence
you said comes greater responsibility I
think Spider-Man was with great power
becomes greater responsibility we do
trivia like breakout groups on the think
media team and the other day Melissa
asked everybody what is your favorite
movie quote and everyone got fired up
they're talking about Lord of the Rings
and and also comedy movies and stuff
will Ferell quotes and stuff uh but but
I think that actually is one of my
favorite quotes from Spider-Man with
great influence comes great
responsibility talk about that because
it's sometimes we think about this idea
stepping into this role of teaching or
educating or entertaining and maybe talk
about how your identity has grown into
that your confidence has grown into that
to get on camera and to to become more
of a leader to become to build to have
personal growth to carry the
responsibility of serving and helping
other people with all the content you
created
I did not imagine that when I
started I I had no idea because each
word that you record stays recorded and
it's going to be replayed Forever Until
you delete that video or do something
different or update that video but um it
is a great responsibility because people
challenge me and um like I've said some
things in my video that I thought it was
right and then people start challenging
me on that and say no this is wrong this
is wrong there wrong that let me go back
to the books and update myself and I was
wrong so I think uh I not I think I I'm
sure having the YouTube channel made me
a better doctor because now I'm a better
Communicator with my patients my
students I teach medical students
residents they say oh but you explain
things so easily that's because I
learned there so the responsibility is
not only with the audience but it's with
everybody around you my family and uh my
friends they see me as a leader as an
influential so anything that you say
comes with that weight they regard you
as the expert in that topic you have to
be very careful what you say don't say
lies and don't sell yourself to sell a
product that you don't believe just
because they're paying you well that is
so ugly that's so unethical so the
responsibility calls for ethics and
ethics is do what your conscience tells
you to do because you're going to regret
later if you say something that um you
really don't want and you have to put
that you have to kill that video If you
regret saying something in that video so
that's the responsibility that I carry
because people are you know looking up
to me and and taking what I say
seriously in each one of those
videos yeah it's so powerful and I do
kind of want to touch on this with just
a personal encouragement to our
challenge Community you know sometimes
we can have
when we see increased responsibility we
shrink back um like man I just don't
want the I don't want the pressure or I
don't want but I want to invite
everybody watching this like you are
built for this and you can handle the
pressure you can handle the
responsibility in fact I think it's one
of the best things for you like I've
learned that when I am just living life
for myself meaning I don't have anybody
else I'm accountable to that's when I
get into trouble but honestly my YouTube
channel more important than that my
marriage to my wife for 18 years my me
being a father to my two boys every time
I felt that higher level of
responsibility it challenged me to
become the next version of myself for
the next season and I've learned this
that YouTube is actually the greatest
personal development experience I've
ever been through books are good
conferences are good but doing YouTube
itself was that invitation to take more
responsibility this also doesn't mean
that you can't make mistakes because
you're going to make mistakes on the
journey but when you start to feel to
step and and here's what I'm trying to
get at I I just want to encourage you to
step
into a bigger place to step into a place
that's outside of your comfort zone to
step into a place of responsibility
because it's almost like pressure makes
diamonds so it's in that place Dr Andrea
just said it it it forced her to become
a better Communicator she improved
because of committing to doing YouTube
I've completely transformed as a as a
human as I've taken on more
responsibility and there's a book called
Extreme ownership by Jo o willik which
is I think one of the most important
books and it is this idea of like you
know sometimes I hear people even
complain other the algorithms against me
or they might complain about life or
circumstances and what if we shifted
this community right here in the
challenge what if we shifted shifted our
mindset we shifted our words and we
stopped complaining we started taking
responsibility what if we stopped
worrying and we got up and took action
and took responsibility what if we just
said I can do this I will build this I
will crash through quitting points I
will keep going when I feel like giving
up I will because I'm responsible it's
like who's going to step up and take
responsability for the troubles we're
facing around the world who's going to
step up in a household as soon as
someone steps up and Clicks in is like
no more I'm taking responsibility this
is where we're going now we're going to
shift the atmosphere we're going to
shift the tone that's what leaders do
they take responsibility and I want to
invite you that if man this might be one
of the most powerful points it's getting
me fired up that your next level of
breakthrough and Views and growth will
be on the next level of you just saying
I'm taking responsibility for it I'm
going viral because I CH I'm I'm GNA do
it I'm Gonna Learn I will until I'm not
going to quit I'm gonna be
responsible and take things to another
level Dr Andre I blame you for that
point no one's ever shared that point
before and so that one really hit me uh
but uh let's hit number 11 and 12 as we
land the plane and then we'll give all
these call to actions to other channels
and all that kind of stuff but Tim hit
this one create your own definition of
success I'm curious about this Dr Andrea
how do you define
success I don't define success by how
many subscribers how many views how many
comments for me success is being able to
record and post one video every week
that for me is a success
uh because it takes a lot of effort to
get to that point and then I leave the
results with God and with YouTube
algorithm because if you compare
yourself with other successful
YouTubers you you know another people
you know other physicians in my field I
may be so sad depressed and I oh I'm not
posting as I'm not having as much
success they're having like with shorts
or with any you know with views and
subscribers but I compare myself with
how I was last month last year so am I
improving yes I'm bringing more people
to my team yes but I am successful if I
can post one video every week because I
I think if you do this there's nothing
if you if you post videos with good
quality with good content this the the
success metrics which is views
subscribers Etc and and money it's just
a consequence so change how you see
yourself and how you measure your own
because those are things that you can
control the number of views you cannot
control man I don't want to riff too
long here we're gonna go back to Tim but
I do think that maybe one thing that
makes theopedia a little bit different
too is one even just asking you this
question and encouraging you to maybe
rethink this question and then two I
think about how we define success here
at think media because
um success ultimately we all have
different opinions but success is the
achievement of a stated goal so in and
of itself to determine if someone's
successful or not of course the world
has its definitions but but the question
becomes what was the goal so it's the
achievement of a stated goal have you
stated your goal and I agree with Dr
Andrea a lot of times we define success
wrong in social media because if you get
even a lot of views well what if they're
the wrong views if you get a lot of
views what if you had to do it
compromise iing your character or your
integrity if you got a lot of use but
you ended up building a business or a
life you didn't love so you just think
about different things like I like to
think about like my ultimate success is
I want the people at the end of my life
to love and respect me the most meaning
I don't want to gain the Applause of the
crowd but lose the love and respect of
my children I want to raise my family
and kids in a house where we love God
love people and where I don't get so
focused on the ambition of growing my
business that I don't grow my marriage
these are different ways I success now
of course these are emblems of success
as well but I like how Dr Andrea said
that um ultimately views I I think are
are byproduct of value so success and
one of the things Dr Andrea hit and this
is worth writing down is there are
results goals and there are action goals
so if you define success by getting a
100 views then you might be disappointed
because you may hit it you may not we'll
have to to see what happens with that
video but if you define success by
uploading a video every week and you go
I'm going to that's a that's a action so
what if your goals were actions not
results like you can't determine if
someone else is going to like you or
love you but you can take the actions to
invest in the relationship and then see
what happens so we take back a lot more
responsibility in personal power and
extreme ownership by owning our actions
I'm going to study this book one chapter
I'm going to watch this module of a
Course once a week or daily that's
checked off the action I'm going to film
my video that's an action and man if you
define success by listen I don't
necessarily control the results but I
can control my actions this was inspired
by you everyone has a different idea of
success go ahead and break down what
this means to you yeah um I know when I
first started um filming some videos I
was excited just to get a certain number
of subscribers so I remember really
clearly when I hit my 10th subscriber I
was so excited when one of my friends
you know reluctantly decided to
subscribe to my channel Channel but then
as the journey went on I would look at
how my videos performed and then I would
be happy if my videos got like 50 views
or then 70 or then 100 views and then as
things start to kind of roll and as you
have like more videos go out there all
of a sudden you kind of want want to hit
higher targets and so like your success
like might have like might lifted to 200
views a video or like a thousand or so
many subscribers so it keeps changing
like the whole way through but I think
it's really important what you said to
like it's also successful for you just
to press record get out there and upload
that video or spend that time editing
because there's a whole lot of work that
can kind of go into this and if you're
prepared to put the hard work in success
will come you know like like nothing
happens without like a lot of hard work
and and if you're consistent with
something if you commit to this and you
say Hey listen you know what I've got
something that I want to share something
that I I feel I can give value to PE to
people with like my knowledge and I'm
just going to keep going on this journey
like one of my favorite singers he used
to his name is Robbie Williams and he
told me that when he started his solo
career mentioned in interview when he
started his solo career he wasn't really
getting anywhere but he just kept on
showing up to the studio every week he
just keep on rolling up things weren't
going great but he just kept on showing
up and if you keep showing up on YouTube
you will have success you know and
you'll like I said you might start off
kind of smaller but then it will
gradually get bigger and bigger and
you'll set bigger and bigger goals as it
goes along as you help more and more
people you know so you know like like
one of my versions of success is
somebody seeing my content and writing
back to me and saying hey man thank you
for your help like I really appreciate
what you did and that to me that that
comment is worth more than 10,000 views
or a million views it's just that I was
successful in helping that person you
know and that that's something that that
you can't buy you know and you might
have like you know changed the direction
of someone's day or um I don't know like
I think it's really really important to
kind of uh to kind of really um honor
the honor the importance of that
communication of somebody communicating
with you because I know that when I was
making some videos a couple years ago I
was uh stuck in hotel isolation I come
back from overseas and I'm I couldn't
get out of my hotel room for two weeks
and I was making videos about my trip to
Singapore and stuff and kind of
wondering is it worth it you know you're
kind of spending all these hours and
you're grinding and you're learning and
you're watching videos and stuff you're
like is anybody really caring and then
there was this Canadian guy who had
something like 30 or 40,000 subscribers
at the time and he wrote to me about one
of my videos I was at changy airport in
Singapore and he said hey man like
you're doing a really good job just kind
of keep on going with your journey you
know like he appreciated what I did and
that little that little small like
little nugget of like someone else's
support you know kind of helping you on
that Journey that kind of gives you that
little extra bit of belief it's like
okay someone is listening and I am able
to help and I am on on the right path
you know because sometimes you can just
think oh my gosh what am I doing this
for I could be spending my time doing so
many other different things but you know
if you just kind of focus on getting
that stuff out there being consistent
like providing that value like and you
will create your own definition of
success on the Jour Journey like for me
like I said getting that feedback is
worth more than a thousand subscribers
you know it's it just kind of means that
you can help another human being you
know and isn't that that the greatest
gift of all right man so inspiring to
hear both of your words and we have
number 12 we're going to hit number 12
here in just a second our final point we
went over the 10 points of course
because there were so many valuable
insights shared as we were preparing for
this session um but also as a reminder
we're going to do the giveaway of a
lifetime membership to video ra Academy
in just a second for one person um a few
other announcements that we'll get to of
course a full shout out to Dr Andrea and
Adventure Tim's channels and how you can
connect with them them and so I hope
you've been getting value out of this
session and I would love like what have
you liked best so far what has stood out
to you so far what resonated with you as
far as action items or insights but
let's hit number 12 number 12
consistency is key consistency is key
and we'll start with Dr Andrea and this
surprised me and I can relate but I'm so
P I'm so grateful you were vulnerable
and you shared this you did say that
there are times that you want to quit
break down the power of consistency
maybe a little bit of that vulnerability
on the Journey of like this isn't always
easy but now looking back and reflecting
on your journey how do you feel what are
some of the
insights uh yeah everybody will have
this you will not be immune um you will
probably post be posting videos and
you're not seeing success or not the
success that you think you deserve and
that you should
have uh and then you said this is not
worthwhile but if you stop there that's
the deep and I read the book that sh
Sean talked about the deep and um and if
you stop there that's where everybody
else stops and that's the hardest point
when you are really you know not getting
the traction that you have but YouTube
is different because YouTube is not a
linear grow line it goes like this and
this and ups and downs and then you get
one video that get get you hundreds of
thousands of um views or for me what
works so interesting when My Views are
going down then one of my older videos a
year two years three years older starts
like it was a flat line and then
suddenly a reason that I have no idea it
becomes like this boom B bom Bo and that
video brings everything
up but you would not notice that if you
had given up so being consistent being
patient take holidays take vacation when
you need from YouTube it is
okay uh but come back and be persistent
if that's your call if that's what you
want to do help people and achieve some
success in this platform you do need to
be persistent and
consistent man stirring words and Tim
you share this you know how if you build
it eventually they will come and you
shared a little bit about that but
unpack this idea of
consistency yeah obviously Field of
Dreams is one of my favorite movies
that's where that line comes from but
yeah like you've just got to keep um
showing up and you got to uh try and
build that relationship and that trust
with your audience you know that you've
got to look at this journey as though
it's not going to happen overnight but
if you just keep working at it like step
by step like it will come and I've kind
of found that by when I committed to v
um I I kind of knew I was on the path to
something that I was going to stick with
you know like you invest your time you
invest your money in it but and then you
kind of tell yourself okay I'm going to
get some value out of this because I'm
investing all this money into it and
then all this time and then if you just
you got to keep posting you got to keep
believing that you know what I can help
people here I can if I keep on pushing
out content if I keep on like sticking
to some kind of program with it um like
good things will happen you know like
and and that's that's one thing that I
think one of your um videos or your
podcast mentions how like something like
75 or 80% of people who start the
YouTube Journey kind of give up or I
don't like giving up I'm not the sort of
person that gives up on people or or
things and I was like well I'm not going
to be that person I'm G to be that one
who's GNA like just keep on sticking
through and just kind of see what
happens and you keep on pushing through
and eventually you're going to break
through that ice and then good things
will happen whether it's you know maybe
a sponsorship deal or maybe you might
get I don't know like a 100,000 views or
whatever but you just got to keep on
pushing and keep keep on working and
Keep On Believing that that what you
have to offer is value valuable to
someone else and by being consistent you
know you're going to grow things are
going to grow for you and don't give up
you know like there's times I could have
given up as well but I just kind of I
just had a message that I wanted to kind
of share and I wanted to help people
like I used to be a English teacher in
Taiwan and I used to love teaching my
kids and I was a swim teacher so I've
always got like an a lot a lot of
personal joy and value out of helping
others and teaching other
and YouTube was like is like another way
when I can do that like when I approach
my GoPro videos sometimes I look at it
like okay I want to imagine that the
person who's picked up a GoPro right now
they have no idea what to do and I think
about like my old man like he's like 85
right like what if he picked up a GoPro
for the first time so I want to speak in
a language where I can kind of help
someone from his level to someone who's
like much more advanced you know and by
being able to be consistent you can help
that person
even like my dad kind of L gradually
kind of get better and better we we keep
putting out consistent content every
week so like I said if you're on the
journey and I know it's hard there's
sometimes you put you want to throw your
hands up and go hey man like is this
worth doing but it is man if you just
keep going you just got to keep pushing
through and good things will come they
really will oh man beautiful 12
incredible points and uh so much value
people have been sharing all their
takeaways and like this is been like a
road map and we've done a lot of these I
think this might be my favorite one you
shared so many cool insights and I feel
like we had very tactical things but
also kind of those deeper um principles
as well that we can build on now let's
start with you Dr Andrea thank you thank
you thank you uh I'll of course share
your channel you're easily findable but
shout out anything that um you uh want
to make mention of and where can people
connect with you yes so the easiest way
is on my channel is just my my name Dr
Andre forland but I also have a website
that I have a lot of handouts and a lot
of things for people to download it's
also my name Dr
andrea.com awesome thank you so much Dr
andrean show her massive love and then
Tim shout out what do you want to
promote or
mention yeah um I'm I can mainly be
contacted through uh my YouTube channel
which is Adventure media that's all one
word or adventure.com which is my uh my
website um I've got Instagram there as
well Adventure _ media and yeah I'm
happy to connect or answer questions
with with anybody else I still kind of
um get into the into the V Facebook page
sometimes too and and read some other
people's comments and some of the things
they're going through and I really
encourage everyone to kind of try to
stay connected to that Community because
that is actually a really really great
resource and especially when I first on
my journey you put up videos and you get
feedback and content from your other
fellow content creators and that's going
be really powerful and I remember there
was uh there was one guy in Montreal the
same about the same time I started and
he had a cooking channel and I used to
just really look forward to seeing his
videos getting posted every week so I
could watch it and support it and then
his success like he blew up a lot before
a lot earlier than I did and then I when
I saw his success I felt so happy for
him because you know we're on the same
pathway so um so yeah um just make sure
if you do join up with v and I I really
encourage it like I said it's kind of
changed so many things for me um yeah
just kind of stay part of that community
and it's all good things are going to
happen right all good things are going
to happen Adventure Tim so grateful for
you thanks so much for being here come
on show some love